foreign
Rock City and talk to Vanessa what's up
Vanessa
Hi how are you partying what are you up
to
oh just
um doing some
grocery shopping some around the house
stuff good good for you that sounds that
sounds more fun than being a podcaster
what's up oh I don't know yeah I know
this is actually kind of a scam of a job
it's pretty cool
what's up
so um I wanted to talk to you about
kind of Brewing inside of me over the
past two years okay and I'm gonna I'm
gonna try and not get emotional so I can
get through through this so I apologize
hey don't ever apologize for getting
emotional on this show you're is you're
you're free free to feel as you wish on
this on the show
so thank you so my question is how do I
maintain
um healthy family unit when I've lost so
much respect for my husband because he's
not the father I need him to be and it
has completely strained our personal
relationship so much that it's just
completely unrecognizable from what it
was
um you know before we had kids
um give me some give me some examples
two-year-old
um our relationship was very quick when
it happened we had an online
relationship and within like eight nine
months we decided we had to be together
and the best thing to do was to get
married so he left his whole life behind
his family his work everything to come
and live with me across the country and
we started basically our new family
together and um the first couple years
of our marriage were quite tumultuous we
were unemployed we didn't have anywhere
to live I suffered connection with half
my family and it only just made our bond
so much stronger was there was there
abuse or was there like what what was
the
what was the the tumultuous part why'd
your family have your family quit
talking to him
because
because and my relationship with him was
quite
um emotionally just very damaging and it
wasn't until I got married that I really
had the courage to kind of stand up to
him and it wasn't anything that my
husband did is just seeing how he
treated me through my husband's eyes
just kind of gave me courage to um stand
up to my father and you know break that
relationship with him and just my
husband was just like with me and for
the first time in your life you you
realized you're not crazy
yeah
crazy okay and that and that I am not
this angry person that I am because like
the second we broke connections with him
like I became this so calm like loving
person and I couldn't recognize myself
and and all it all had to do because I
was just under so much mental stress
okay diets of it and so I have so much
you know to thank to my husband for it
he didn't actually do anything all he
did was love me and support me he didn't
do you know so so fast forward you have
a two-year-old now how have things
changed when you say you're disappointed
in the father he is
we talked about when we got married we
were on the same page bring it out Bring
me to now things change over the course
of a decade bring me to right now
so he is very disconnected from um our
child I became a mom overnight you know
and I tried to give him so much time to
adjust to being a father I know all you
know some men you know it takes time but
he is so disengaged he's disengaged from
our new family we go to do family things
and he chooses to stay home and find
things to to do at home and it's just
it's gotten to the point over two years
that I have not seen any growth in him
as you know a husband a father because
he can't just be a husband anymore right
he has to be his father now and our
relationship has strained so much we
used to be so good together and it's
just
got out the window and no one had like
we've never had like big fights or
anything like that it's kind of like
just this call that's now hanging above
us
so um he's not on the phone with me I'd
love to talk to him if he ever wants to
call in I'd love to talk to him because
I here's my promise to you he doesn't
like the way things are either
I'm sure of it but I want to paint you a
picture and possibly give you a few
things now when I give you a few ideas
I don't want you to take these ideas as
though this is your fault in any way
okay
but here's the deal it's there's a great
saying um not by your hand but in your
lap
you didn't make all of this happen
exactly the way this was you played a
role you're married you're a part of
this ecosystem but you didn't cause all
this
but the hurt is sitting in your lap
right so I'm going to give you a few
ideas of things that you can do but I
don't want you or any of the listeners
walking away being like I can't believe
you blamed her for this because that's
not what I'm doing at all not even not
even a tiny bit okay fair same same team
yeah okay
it is super super common
for
a baby to be born
and dad looks at this baby
and he's been told by every every
Instagram account every Pastor in his
life every whatever when you hold that
baby everything's different yeah
and you hold that baby
and everything is not different you're
just scared to death
because you don't know what to do
and I'm not saying anything Vanessa but
maybe in this situation he has a very
strong wife
who has a very clear picture about the
way things are going to be done and the
way they're going to look
that's not how you do that you do it
like this you do it like this no no no
no you do it like this how come you
didn't do that why didn't you know that
about that
so I'm very aware of of this and that's
why I have not said any of that okay
hold on hold on hold on hold on let me
let me finish okay because I'm not
blaming here I'm just walking alongside
you
so
and
possibly
over it happens by degrees and I don't
know any guy who has thought this out
loud
but it happens by degrees which is I'm
not good at fill in the blank
yeah I'm trying to do diapers right I'm
trying to to be able to read like should
I get up right now should I help right
now should I just sit right here what am
I like and absent some very clear
helpful instructions it's tough but
here's what many good men do
they say I'm not good here
but I'm going to be awesome at work
or I'm going to make sure this car is
running like a top and the roof is
always fixed and the yard looks perfect
because that's a thing they know how to
do and they can convince themselves that
that's a thing that helps the family
which in a way it is
and then wife is sitting here feeling
that slow peel away
and you snap your fingers and you blink
and it's two years and you find yourself
four inches apart on the couch and you
know four thousand miles away from each
other right
and so I promise
based on what you've told me about who
this guy was and the role he's played in
your life I bet he would give everything
to have a close relationship with this
kid
but maybe he's never had an opportunity
to have a two-year-old go no Daddy and
run away and not realize it it's not
because he's a terrible father but it's
because there's a knuckleheaded little
two-year-old
yeah I see that happening a lot and I
see him getting hurt because when my
son's like no and then he you know she
doesn't want anything to do with him and
he's like well you see I tried yeah and
I can see him getting his feelings hurt
and I'm trying to remind him you know
he's just too you know but so and listen
if he was on the phone with me I would
tell him those moments sting and I don't
care you got to keep showing up and you
gotta keep showing up
because that will change to something
fun and that will change to something
silly
or a lot of dads try to start imposing
life lessons on two-year-olds it's I was
the worst
like my son would do something and I
would be like that's not the kind of man
we're gonna be oh my gosh he's two he's
two right we need to play with balloons
in mud and soccer balls and sticks and
fish like this is not the moment for
life lessons he's absorbing life lessons
from me at the at the at the
mitochondrial level but my explaining
crap to my two-year-olds is no good and
all I have to say is this
often men find themselves
in these moments with their tool kit and
it only has three Tools in it one of
them is was given to them by their their
dad
and their dad also gave him four other
ones that they threw out because they
were no good
and it's really really frustrating for a
wife
who has a very clear picture of how she
wants this thing to look
and so the only path forward is not this
moment of my husband sucks he's not the
man I wanted him to be he's not the dad
I want him to be
it's an understanding that every single
moment of your life is different now
what was is now over
it's gone
and that's not a bad thing because what
you can rebuild and what you can become
would be can be infinitely better than
what was you thought it was fun just
having this cool fun relationship where
y'all made out all the time and y'all
just went out to eat all the time and
all that that was awesome
yeah
you can have that times a hundred when
you have a kid you've got you're doing
life together you're building something
amazing together he's coming home dead
asleep because he's so tired from
working so hard and you are coming home
and you're dead asleep from Raising all
the stuff it's this beautiful thing
here's here's um
here's my path forward if I was you okay
okay I would take him out
and say we're gonna go eat somewhere and
I want you to get a babysitter
so it's just y'all too
and I want you to be open about the
things that you wish you could have back
now
again please know in not one ounce am I
blaming you for any of this zero
but I want you I understand that I want
you to be the person who lights the fire
for this thing to move forward
and if you sit down and and y'all go to
breakfast together and you plan on
spending three or four hours at this
restaurant and you're gonna create begin
to build a blueprint for this new life
because now you've got kids
and you sit down that table and say
you're not being the dad you're not
being the husband you're not being the
man that I knew then he has to throw a
wall up to defend himself
right so at that point
listen to anything yeah he checks up and
you probably have done that before right
maybe maybe maybe
one whatever so here's what I want you
to do I want you to sit down and say
I'm sorry
if I could do this all over again the
moment I found that I was pregnant we
would have been right here at this very
table dreaming about what our life could
look like together and here's my picture
of being a parent what's your picture of
being a parent and what scares you about
being a dad and what are things that you
don't have any idea what's coming
because Vanessa I'm telling you I was a
pretty plugged in Dad I really wanted to
be good at it and I had no idea about
how some of this stuff worked
and I went to the internet to try to
find things there's not a lot of help
for dads to be helpful around the house
and then I went to some of the Christian
literature and it's trash it's nonsense
it's awful
and so I got stuck and then I decided
I'm just going to be so great at work
I'm gonna be amazing at work because I
I'll make a bunch of money for my family
and so some very good talking points
um
if you could re-do it again what would
you do differently you know from the
beginning but you go first you say I
would have been more clear I would have
told you oh my gosh kids poop 400 times
a day and until the kids about three
they're gonna toggle between lots of
hugs and lots of no dad no and it's not
personal they're just a bundle of nerves
and so when they say no dad and they run
away then you can say Here Comes they
can be turned into some silly game
yeah or you can just get a hose and go
pour it outside in your backyard until
it just turns into a small mud hole and
dad can just plop down in it in his
shorts
and the kid will just sit down and y'all
can smear mud all over each other and
that kid will tell that story at his
funeral because he'll see the pictures
he won't remember it right it's it's
it's both completely recalibrating this
thing with very clear Direction and
instruction
and maybe you give him permission to say
how have I made this hard for you
husband
yeah and give him an opportunity to
speak
but I promise you based on what you've
told me about him he doesn't want to be
here either
yeah and then if you leave this
breakfast
with
we have a United picture of what
parenting is going to look like once a
week he's going to have kid all to
himself even screams cries all that some
of the greatest gifts I had was that my
wife taught graduate school two nights a
week and I had Hank all by myself
and he would scream he would cry he
would have just regular newborn issues
that I had no idea what I was doing
um but I had to figure it out I had to
figure it out I had to call old friends
I had to call old buddy I'd call
everybody and but I had to figure it out
and so all to say is y'all come up with
whatever roadmap works for you
and instead of sitting back and being
like he's failing me he's not the guy I
married
let's lean back in with some very clear
on these nights I need help with
I would like to spend two nights a week
just watching a show after the baby's
gone down or while I'm feeding the baby
and you just hold my hand and we watch a
show
will you just rub my shoulders and tell
me that I'm pretty for about the next 30
minutes please
would you right let's be very specific
and if this was Hollywood it would be so
awesome if he just knew all the stuff by
osmosis he doesn't
he doesn't
and if you do all this y'all lay this
out and he he commits you commit you're
in and then come Monday and for the next
six weeks after that he just goes back
to work now you got a problem
because now he's choosing I'm gonna go
back to what's easy I'm gonna go back to
what I know I'm gonna go back to
checking out
and then there's a time for grief and a
time for for marriage counseling
but I think based on what you've told me
you're in and he's in and you want this
thing to work and I promise he wants
something different and like I say I'm
happy to talk to him if he wants to call
in
but I'd love for you all to go out and
just say okay we have a whole new life
now we're two years into kid one we may
have more than one kid
here's what I would do differently and
I'm sorry
what are some ways you've experienced me
over the last few years what are some
things that scare you to death about
this baby
as he's getting older or she's getting
older let's start there
I'm highly optimistic for you guys
Vanessa I'm really proud of you I'm
really proud of you